we're taking a closer look at
developments in the south pacific today
specifically the solomon islands it is
planning a security deal with china and
the idea of chinese warships based less
than 2 000 kilometers off the australian
coast off its northeast has set alarm
bells ringing in fact even the united
states is worried the white house has
plans to send its top asia official kurt
campbell to the small nation later this
month
the ongoing battle for influence between
china and the west is shifting to the
south pacific
beijing is upping its presence a draft
agreement would allow chinese police and
soldiers to patrol the solomon islands
the five eyes intelligence alliance
britain canada australia and new zealand
fears china is eyeing a naval base there
the solomons have long been seen as
australia's backyard
the archipelago is a long way from china
but it's just a three-hour flight from
brisbane
australian and new zealand leaders are
not happy
the what the reports that we've seen are
not a surprise to us and a reminder of
the constant pressure and threats
that present in our region to our own
national security look we new zealand
has long expressed an opinion that we do
not want to see the militarization of
the pacific that we believe we can
support one another with defense and
security needs as they arise and new
zealand has a history of doing that in
the solomon islands
solomon islands switched diplomatic ties
from taiwan to beijing in 2019 which
partly fueled discontent that led to
riots in the capital honiara in november
last year
chinese businesses were attacked in the
unrest
solomon islands prime minister manesse
sagavar dismisses critics of the treaty
with china as lunatics disrespectful of
the island's sovereignty
we have no intention mr speaker of
pitching into any geopolitical power
struggle
to suggest that mr speaker is simply
ludicrous
as a sovereign country mr speaker
we will continue
to collaborate
to ensure
that what solomon islands needs
in its security space are addressed
collectively
with our development partners
china wants to build a blue water navy
capable of projecting power around the
world
to make this work it needs bases from
which to service a strike force
china tries to play down fears it wants
to expand in the region and blames
australia for promoting u.s led
competition
as two independent and sovereign
countries china and solomon islands can
carry out normal law enforcement and
security cooperation
on the basis of equal treatment and
mutual benefit
the west has been stunned by the speed
with which china has moved to militarize
the man-made islands in the south china
sea
a move to solomon islands increases the
risk of escalation and potential
conflict
joining us in the studio is dw's
clifford conan clifford tell us more
about this proposed security deal i
thought australia had some kind of
relationship with the solomon islands it
does it already has a security deal and
it also has a very complicated and
intertwined relationship with the
solomon islands um you know as as we
mentioned the report it's a two-hour
flight from brisbane um and the south
pacific is seen very much as australia's
backyard its sphere of influence
and it gives 1.3 billion us dollars
every year in development aid and it has
various other security guarantees when
there was unrest there in november last
year they sent um security forces there
to to shore up the unrest so they do
have this very complicated relationship
but um it's also very uh um difficult
balancing act in many ways for australia
as we can see in a quote here from from
scott morrison
as a friend of solomon islands we remain
their first call for security we remain
the first call when it comes to the
issues uh that concern them right across
their development eye the suggestion
that somehow some seem to be making that
that solomon islands is somehow under
the control of australia i think is
offensive to the solomon islands they
are a sovereign nation i respect their
independence and they will make their
own decisions about their own
sovereignty what we have been doing is
ensuring that they are fully aware of
the risks and the security matters that
are not only of concern to australia but
ireland's pacific nations across the
pacific
so i think there what that comment shows
that if you look at it from the solomon
islands perspective you know they're
151st in the 189 uh countries on the u.n
human development index so it's a poor
country
it needs australia's help but then china
can also offer economic guarantees as
well as security guarantees
so it's a very vulnerable country with a
lot of needs
i think a lot of people in asia probably
looking at the situation and wondering
the parallel with the south china seas
because this potential security
agreement can quickly turn into a very
permanent military installation can you
talk a little bit about that
sure well china wants to establish
itself as the premier power broker in
the indo-pacific and it's done this
through various means through trying to
um broker deals with various countries
usually economic guarantees uh in some
ways solomon islands is unusual because
it's it's a straightforward security
guarantee which is something that we've
seen in djibouti in africa before but um
we haven't really seen it so much in the
region near to china so um it does have
a lot of parallels there um we've seen
how china has militarized these three
islands
which are near the philippines which has
led recently to the philippines talking
to japan all these countries all of
china's neighbors basically have some
kind of territorial dispute with china
and because of china's efforts to expand
its influence so um there are parallels
with that and um
i think we're going to see more and more
of that as things go on now australia is
part of the quad together with the
united states uh india japan and you
also recently have had the agreement uh
between
australia the uk and the u.s in terms of
providing nuclear-powered submarines so
china can sort of say hey this is
encirclement it feels like it and we
have the right to engage with the
solomon islands if we want to well china
generally says whenever this comes up it
says that it's only doing what the u.s
has done before that its sphere of
influence is pretty much where it
decides um the solomon islands is a long
way away from china
now you can see it as an extension
because it's in the pacific area and
china wants to basically control the
pacific um but so encirclement is one
argument but in reality this is more
just about trying to control the pacific
um and it's interesting mark milley the
joint chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff he said recently that china is
trying to um
is trying to break the established
system of rule of law and one of the
areas that he focused particularly on
was the navy and i think um watching
watching the sort of china's efforts to
control the marine they're developing a
lot of their technological advances are
focused on on naval vessels for example
they're going to have a new aircraft
carrier which launches by catapult and
they're also trying to develop an
aircraft carrier that's a
nuclear-powered aircraft carrier so
there's a lot of technological
advancement there's a lot of defense
spending going into controlling the navy
and that i think you know shows just how
focused
the the chinese china is on the on the
so china sea and the whole pacific yeah
i mean if you look at the maps the
solomon islands are so far away from
china so really quickly i mean
ratcheting up of tensions in the pacific
huh i think so i think that's what we're
looking at now for now there's just
going to be a succession of these sort
of deals being struck there's a lot of
small countries in the area a lot of
small island states a lot of them with
very great strategic importance so
certainly more tensions in the asia
pacific
clifford coonan thank you so much as
always for joining us
you